even if you get higher education no
almost
no major can actually prepare you to
today's job market
and and and workplaces those are the
places kind of you know
give you the skills and teach you the
hands-on
[Music]
thank you so much for taking time out of
your busy schedule to be with me how are
you
great i'm really happy and excited to
join you on this session today
thank you very very much noah if i begin
to list
the different things that you've done uh
i would the 20 minutes would be
fast over but just for reference so that
we can structure the conversation a
little bit
you're starting out you're you're
running marketing for
a startup colu you're you're head of
community
for that for ebay you're today you're
the head of
the israeli delegation to washington dc
but you're also a speech writer
for a very famous politicians which you
managed to put in your your
your children's names in there from time
to time right but but the
but one of the most important things i
think is that you competed against only
cost beyond
on a a trivia game show we did
indeed and last and lost
thought tell me about that experience
you're in who's the last
standing right yes yes true and i was
testified you know being in front of the
basketball player and i'm like oh
they're going to ask me so many
questions about sports and if there's
something i'm not good at it's like
sports questions and um i end up
losing to a question about a book
which is my passion my hobby my
major you studied
yeah literature was very true i would
say it's not a very good one
it's not a very good book the one that i
missed so i'm kind of okay with
losing on that one but um i love it i
love it not you know
even when i was listing the things and
it's important for me not to have
anything written because i try to have
the spontaneous but i forgot to mention
that you
also just casually co-founded one of the
leading job search platforms in israel
which we'll get to as well but not talk
to me about your your life journey
because that's fascinating you're
starting out with literature you're
writing his speeches for famous
politicians
which i want to hear about what that's
like and then you all of a sudden find
yourself in the text scene so
start from the speech writing and then
let's move on to the text scene
so if we go even further and i actually
started as an educator because like
everybody else i wanted to
change the world for better i guess i
just wanted the world to make the world
a better place and i said well education
would be
it probably right especially in israel
when you have so many
minority groups and such a huge gap in
between certain populations so i said
okay i'm gonna
deep dive into that my original uh kind
of say ambition would be
um like the minister of education
and then i said a teacher would be a
good start i'd say
and i thought that would be the most
effective way everybody goes through the
education system
uh at the same time i'm also working in
a big philanthropy organization
with um students it came from a
disadvantaged background kind of
enabled them to get higher education and
get the best out of that
time period and while i was doing
all that for sure impact i still felt
that i was
kind of restraining between these
literally four walls
sometimes and i felt that um if i
in person want to get a jump start but
also with the impact i want to create
um tech would be eat it's this is the
way to go
um if we want to kind of you know
prepare the the
generation of the future we should
definitely um
skill the skill them up with those areas
and i thought that would be you know the
best
thing to do and because i had the social
um social media
non-profit startup i'd say i was um
i was pretty good with everything
related to social media and online
marketing and so that was kind of my
ticket
to make that transition and i started
but i don't have to say no i'm gonna i'm
stumbling for a second because
that's exactly a point that i keep
thinking about it's about you what you
just talked about was scale right you're
saying i'm making an impact it's between
four walls my every minute that i put
into a day
i you can pretty much know okay this is
the impact that i'm producing
and how do i now make it make this
impacted skill so that i can impact
millions of people
and i'm sure that the work that you were
doing with it with the students in
physically in front of you changed their
lives but
but then you're thinking okay how can i
now do this at scale and change millions
of peoples of lives right
yeah exactly so scaling is it you know
tekken scale is that so it's kind of
doing automation
of impact i would say and so um
that that kind of you know that's how i
uh made that transition into
uh tech it's obviously this could be a
whole conversation to itself because i
know many people have that kind of
ambition
to to do that transition to both ways by
the way i get a lot of calls from people
the other way around and also it's
there's a language it's not just the
language
you know it's translating your resume
from let's say hebrew to english it's
translating your resume from
english to to you know tech or whatever
language
um it is and each in each kind of sector
has its own lingual and and kind of uh
inner world and inside classic with our
minister of technology moving from vc
to the public sector but but you're
right the transition is both ways but
yeah sorry
i mean i keep interrupting you go ahead
no you're that that's it i told you i
want to hear more about you and
speak about myself i don't know do it
the other around this time
um and yeah so um i started off at um
at in tech in a in a fintech startup
which was
completely kind of out of my comfort
zone and i do give you know a huge
curtis to
this startup that saw the potential in
me and it was kind of you know a smart
move
also from my end to to you know to give
an opportunity to an early stage startup
because this this is also kind of
a kind of a tip for people who were
seeking to do that transition
and uh it was the best school i could
think of
working in a startup especially in
israel it's like it's
there it's like 30 hours a day or i
don't know 36 hours a day instead of 24.
it's
you learn so much and it was um it was
literally the the best school and i do
believe that um employ
employers and also companies are the
schools
of today if we mentioned education and
so on so
um even if you get higher education no
almost no major can actually prepare you
to today's job market and
and and workplaces those are the place
that kind of you know
give you the skills and teach you the
hands-on
uh work so yeah so that was kind of the
the first
step and all along i kept on having my
uh
job search platform which i co-founded
with a friend named donna
and um yeah which also kind of you know
made it very loud and clear because i
was talking to job seekers
to thousands and tens of thousands and
and even more of job seekers but at the
same times to employers and i could see
uh very clearly kind of this gap in
between you know you write your resume
hope for the best do whatever you can to
to
put yourself into words and then you
send them out and hope that someone gets
them but we all know that
uh even if they get them they they get a
chance to read so few of them so that's
kind of uh
definitely um um a market disruption
that i
i care a lot about and no and obviously
i have to say that you're being very
humble
by just saying that you co-founded this
platform this is one of the most popular
platforms in as well for job searching
with with i believe hundreds of
thousands of visitors
per month and tens of thousands of
active and of active engagements and
we're talking about here you know
people's lives people's livelihoods this
is not just another
product this is literally finding people
jobs for some people it's to get food on
the table for others it's
it's for it's for different fulfillments
so so that's that's incredible
not you move from colu to uh to ebay
and you're talking now you're about
community and you're about engagement
what does that mean to you so yeah and
first of all thank you so
for putting that in in such good wording
because
people keep on asking i've been doing it
for over than 10 years and we have a
group of seven volunteer and people are
like why are you doing it we do it
voluntarily we don't we're not
for this amazing we're not getting paid
and when people
ask me like do you not feel in here with
a special word for it fire
fly which do not feel like you know you
get you you're able to get so much money
out of this and i like i want to make
sure
i keep it free for both sides so people
so
organization would be more than happy to
send us as many
as many as possible as many jobs as
possible especially during covert
at the same time we're gonna keep it
free for those who are
job-seeking and we all know that that
can be the toughest time
um out of someone's lives um
yeah so if you're impacted skill about
community
so you know this is this is pretty
smooth because if we're talking about
community i guess it's exactly it it's
been able to
um to to in in a way to advance your
life and and i do think when you talk
about
um online communities and and facebook
and
and social media many of the times you
would find
you would hear people criticize it and
say it's shallow
and it's a waste of time and it's only
you know
self-bragging and so on and i do believe
that
we can use social media and and even
even so even online marketing
to benefit our life to become better
parents
i get ton of advice i'm sure i'm a
better mom since i've been using
you know like mom groups and parents
groups online and
sure makes us better professionals um
and and honestly it's just like it's
it's i i do believe this is the way to
go and if you talk about
um companies and tech companies i think
for
everyone it is very clear that all days
marketing the one that you think of a
slogan of a catchphrase you think of the
best image
it's just not enough none of us is going
to make
no decision of you know what cell phone
to buy because
they have gal gadot which i love yeah i
don't know
all of us do but it's just not enough
i'm not going to get something just
because they have you know
an amazingly beautiful face on it i'm
gonna do it because
you know because i'm gonna find this uh
blog
or just a friend or a facebook group
that i appreciate and i'm gonna search
and i'm gonna
see some reviews and make up my mind
based on that more than anything else
and
and this goes for and see almost
everything you do if you think about it
and also studies shows that 40 of the
consumer choice that we made are based
on
an er ear to mouth right ear to mouth
and this is how we make our choices
today and and that's why reviews are so
are so big and so many startups and
companies are
around reviews but it's at the same time
community and
consumer community or product community
um this is honestly this is the way to
go and
and ebay the bus i had which it's also a
funny story
he heard me interviewed on another
podcast about
online communities and wow and they
wanted
when the site in israel wanted to to to
try and kind of put up
a team for that they were looking for a
team lead
and so you over he heard me on that
podcast and so
uh so he reached out and it was it was
so funny because
um it was exactly that they wanted to do
this experiment
where they take their users their
product users around a certain area and
kind of build a community around it and
see how we
cure products better how we
we create an inner community let's say
if it's if it's buyers on ebay or amazon
how do you
create their own inner community to
share your problem
best practices and so on that is uh
fascinating i think that what you said
before which really resonated with me
you said that it's
that the the pretty face and the the
logo and the and the messages it's not
enough and
and i and i hear some people say that
that that
branding and marketing has changed i
don't think the changes are but what
you're saying is it's evolved
right it's it is still important it's
still important to have
the great people presenting it's the
messaging is important the logo is
important
but now for me to want to buy a cell
phone to for me to want to
to to engage with the product i need
something more i need to feel a part of
the community
and and i think that that's just
something fascinating that that really
feels like it's
something out of the last five or six
years right that it's really becoming
more and more common
and which is i think incredible but but
i want to make sure we have enough time
also to talk about what you're doing
today
because today you're talking from
washington dc right
yes what are you doing there yeah
basically kind of the same but just
different
um the idea is to have uh israeli or
a representative live here um in america
working with the community here in
america and kind of working on the
connection
between uh between israel and
working on that relationship to kind of
uh make it more depth than what you hear
on the news
and read on right you know on social
media so this is kind of to create
the deaf relation relationship in
between
and yeah i i'm leading a group here and
also moved here with my family on this
adventure
again kind of following um following
passion
i guess and and i definitely um uh
love doing that and i do believe that in
some aspects
we can definitely some aspects and best
practices we can
bring from outside of the country here
to america and definitely learn from
different cultures i can say that
facebook groups in israel are so big um
studies show that um people in israel
spend their time at least in two or
three facebook group and really
for consumer but also for every other
aspect in their life and
when we had a session uh all like a
community
of people who lead big community groups
and and
uh communities online through facebook
so we met there
on um gm of of israel and she said that
uh
israel is really the kind of the the the
top of that
pyramid with with uh with innovation
around kind of community
i guess because you know it's a it's a
good sandbox for those things it's a
small place everybody knows
everyone and and definitely um
yeah so again you're taking a community
but you're going
from tech now back to a to community and
to
to i'm guessing that there is a little
bit of a difference
between running the community and
engagement for a startup
then for a big corporation and now for
more of the government and more for
social issues right yeah and and kind of
even even i don't know maybe
even diplomat in a way but i can tell
you that throughout you know the last
decade that i've been doing it in
different
aspects you can see that some kind of
the essence
run the same i mean people are one wants
to
kind of they want to find their their
peers or people they can relate to they
want to get they want to get
knowledgeable
from from those areas and
i i i'd say i think kind of a difference
between a and
non-community or a community kind of or
between the old marketing and the new
marketing will
will be around two things one of them
would be that the communication
is both ways it's not just you know
a company or organization or social
cause
shouting out their message it goes both
ways and that one i can speak very close
from working in a startup because you
have your
uh road map and your you know the
product team have their plans and
not want to hear any any feedback from
up the street and kind of make
but if you're a good community manager
and a more advanced marketer you would
bring that um
information back to the team i can give
you just a
tiny example when i worked for calls
it's a payment app like
venmo and and and we got
the and it was new five years ago in
israel no one used um a payment i
remember i
remember when it was brand new yeah yeah
so okay so thank you you probably got
tons of emails from me not from colu it
was
me and said no one used it and we had to
kind of you know educate the market and
so we asked people why don't you feel
confident uh
we ask you what's kind of your feedback
and many of them said they don't feel
confident enough within their credit
card
information and so you know we just
added like the symbol
uh the the icon of a lock
and even that just increased the the
course
wow trust in maybe 30 percent and happen
and it's just a tiny example of how
feedback from users can really change uh
your your your product and your
everything and so that's
one major thing that the book the two
side communication and the other thing
is to create
um a space for people to communicate
with each other
and that also was the big thing because
if you're talking a about a tech
product you would say why is it
important to us but we even just by
writing
uh focus group they have an opportunity
to of the top
users where they get opportunity to
communicate between
themselves you can actually create
not just users but um but passionate
passionate uh community members of your
own product and
many before me you know yelp they built
their oh
they're that's the that's basically how
they built themselves up
bottom up and no it's a
just fascinating it's so so relevant to
everything that's happening to them and
the whole evolution of
companies brands engagement community
that's it's just
fascinating work that you're doing and i
just love how you you're gaining all
these different
extraordinary experiences half of which
we didn't even get to really dive deep
in
in and talk about which and that's why i
keep you know beating myself on the head
that i
that i call this 20 minute leaders are
not 30 minute leaders because
oftentimes i just want to continue but
unfortunately i have to now thank you
for being so generous with your time and
i have to ask you the last question
which is three words that you would use
to describe yourself
so i would say the first one would
probably be passion
um i hope it goes through it
100 everything i do i'd say probably the
second thing would be um a community
it's something i care about through
everything i do
and the third one which i had the
hardest time choosing maybe because it's
the last one
um i'd say um i'd say maybe
uh um adjustable or kind of
uh um yeah yeah being
dynamic adjustable yeah because you know
people say people translate what darwin
said
and you know they sometimes you would
hear someone said
that he said that the stronger survives
but if you look closely at their
translation it says that it was more
adaptive that's who survived and i think
that's kind
of you know our generation and our
future generation
and the the reality that we live today
being adaptive
and being able to adjust to whatever you
know comes your way
um that's kind of uh the way to survive
i guess but but also to enjoy not just
surviving
yeah thank you so so much this was just
wonderful thank you for all the
incredible work that you're doing
whether it's helping thousands of people
find jobs or helping
helping spread the message of israel in
in in
a better light and in a more correct
light with with actual deep meaning and
not just
and not just headlines from either sides
and
i i i'm just looking forward to continue
learning from you from all your journey
and continue maintaining this
relationship so thank you very much
thank you thank you so much